[Music]
the parents of the young American man
beaten to death in Greece while on
vacation are speaking for the first time
in an interview that you'll see only on
CBS this morning
Macari Henderson was his name he died
last month on the Greek island of
Zakynthos surveillance video captured
his final moments as a mob chased him
out of the bar and then surrounded him
on the street his parents Jill and Phil
Henderson invited us to their home in
Austin Texas they told us about the son
that they called the hype man of the
family he had big plans and a very
positive presence the name Bakari is
very unusual what does it mean it means
of noble promise of noble promise did he
live up to that name oh yeah and he was
proud of it but Carrie Henderson showed
plenty of promise as a recent graduate
of the University of Arizona at 22 years
old he had already traveled the world
and last month he was in Greece to get a
new venture off the ground he was there
for and a photo shoot for his new
clothing line that he was launching Phil
that originally said well maybe you
should you know have a plan B and he
said well Plan B's for people who aren't
confident in their plan a your response
to that was it's it's typical Bakari I
just laugh I said okay akari
it seems was up for a challenge this
video was shot the day before his
parents noticed a missed phone call in
the middle of the night from the US
Embassy I was thinking maybe okay you
found his wallet he's over there and
he's trying to get to another country
what's going on so when I called and I'm
hoping because it's that night call you
yeah
don't want so I'm just hoping we pray
before we even called her back you did
oh yeah oh yeah you prayed before you
called her we pray because it was coming
from he was just prayed that Picard was
okay but the news was devastating their
youngest son had been killed after an
altercation in a Serbian bar a woman
told authorities it started when she
asked for a selfie with Bukhari she says
a Serbian man asked her why are you
talking to a black guy before hitting
Bakari in the face do you think this was
a racially motivated instead
or do you just think it was just
something that was out of control and he
just happened to be the unlucky victim
here how it started may not have started
that way it may have started out as an
American issue and then resulted in you
know a black American tragedy
your son was a world traveler and
clearly very comfortable traveling
around the world true yes more
comfortable overseas than in the United
States so this desire what do you mean
well he just felt it was safer over in
Europe and overseas in general he said
you know with the climate with
african-american males in the u.s. that
he just felt more comfortable overseas
isn't that ironic that he could say to
you I feel more comfortable in another
country other than my own yes and he
ends up losing his life in another
country for what reason we still don't
know exactly nine suspects face charges
of voluntary manslaughter for the
violent beating which happened shortly
after the attackers chased bukhari out
of the bar
Jill Phyllis looked at the tape of that
night and you've just you've chosen not
to write because well I just want to
keep his memory alive and I don't want
to introduce any negativity into my
spirit and I really do want to remember
him as they go lucky energetic
fun-loving happy Bakari I missed that
about him and I just miss his energy his
hugs his laughs his loud boisterous
laugh I mean his smile just everything
he just brightens up a room I'm gonna
miss this just it's competitive for this
[Music]
whenever a sporting event come on he
calls boxing to me whatever it is soccer
he loved it and I'm just gonna miss that
I know if your friends been very hopeful
for you both to get you through the
whole family is feeling the void
including younger sister Jory and older
brother PJ what we miss most BJ
I'm just talking right now we'd be
talking about the Cowboys and eagles
right now is talking sports loose they
took us to a mural that a stranger
painted of bukhari shaded in purple his
mom says that was his favorite color
it also coats the walls of his bedroom I
knew there would be a lot of trophies in
here that's where they shared something
special this is a recording it was a
prayer Bakari led on a family phone call
last June asking God for health and
peace around the world those words
really resonate in this household as
these parents try to make sense of their
son's brutal death you know I first
thought what parents would raise such
barbarians to do such an evil thing to
another human being and then the Holy
Spirit just kind of spoke to me and said
you know what it's bigger than that is
so much bigger than that because the
world that we live in today our leaders
sit back and they just almost condone
this type of behavior so they don't
condemn it and by their silence they
promote it and so I think in order for
us to move forward we're gonna have to
do better in general what is it that
you're still seeking what is it that you
still want we want justice for Bakari
and justice to you would mean what
justice would mean to have everyone
involved to be locked up and hopefully
for a very long time now the family has
hired a lawyer they say they plan to be
there in Greece to represent their son
when the case goes to trial a pair of
GoFundMe pages has raised more than
$100,000 to cover those cost in the
meantime the Hendersons tell us they've
heard nothing from members of Congress
members of the state other than a phone
call from Senator John Cornyn Sophos
when they were trying to bring Bakari
remains home last
that's something guys this is still so
fresh this just happened early July and
they're only speaking up because they
want to bring attention of course to the
case they don't want this case to be
forgotten and you know it was
heartbreaking to be there the couple's
been married 30 years great family
planning a big family celebration that
Bakari was involved in planning then
they're just as a big hole where there
was a lot of life in that house and it's
just very very sad I know they have not
spoken publicly until now went with you
and it's just so painful to hear I know
what happened to him they've hired a
lawyer here in New York and they've
hired a lawyer in Greece but it's very
difficult dealing with a foreign country
and they are hoping that somebody in the
government will step in and help them it
sounds like a good man very good he was
really really good man